all right good morning everyone
uh representative groda is sitting in
for representative hatch who is not here
and we do have a quorum
is there anything to come off consent
uh yes 2023-55
which is
it is an employment rule regarding
uh EMP 300. okay
anything else to come off consent any
discussion
do we have a motion
okay those in favor
aye opposed
all right
um
how are the minutes director Morrow
uh they should be fine unless anybody
has noticed something okay does anyone
have any any
comments or corrections to the minutes
and do we have a motion
okay I moved by uh
Schmidt second by Ward is there any
discussion of the minutes
seeing none those in favor
aye aye those opposed
okay that takes here are the minutes
on to the regular get home
all right mental health and
developmental services
foreign
there's a conditional approval on this
and
um I have no comments I believe that the
rule complies with the statute however
um there was some testimony and so I
think there are still some questions
okay
um
as I recall the issue we had was about
not being clear about not throwing
people out on the street when they're
being evicted for uh
bad behavior essentially could could you
explain your uh what what changes you
made to it
sorry I thought it I did it the wrong
way good morning Melissa Nemeth um with
Health and Human Services uh so the
changes that were made we we first met
in
um
April and we made changes based on that
to section 3 10 10
letter C numbers one and four
um the request at that time was to
provide Clarity that when these folks
received that initial notification from
their provider that they were seeking to
have them leave the residents that they
were notified right up front that that
did not mean they had to leave at the
end of that period that there would be
another notice and that at that point
they would have the opportunity to
appeal so those are the changes that
have been made to this point there's
been some subsequent testimony from
others I don't know if you would like me
to address that or if you would like to
wait for public testimony or if you
either way is fine with me okay uh so on
does the committee have any questions
about the the changes that were made
I don't have any questions but I I tend
to think that what the witness suggested
makes sense to maybe we hear from other
Witnesses and then have have or come
back if that's acceptable to the chair
okay
fine I do have a from
Karen Rosenberg from the disability
rights Center
good morning everyone for the record I'm
Karen Rosenberg I'm the policy director
at the disability rights Center and I'm
circulating a couple of documents that I
believe I submitted electronically one
which was the letter to this committee
and following your May meeting but I
didn't know if you all had a hard copy
and then the second document is one that
I brought with me to our last your last
meeting so um I didn't know if you had
that in front of you so that's helpful
to refer to I thought you might have it
so um
follow at the last meeting what what I
explained to the committee and I think
what the committee understood is that in
order to be eligible for federal
matching dollars for our home and
Community Based Services programs for
people with developmental disabilities
and acquire brain injuries who are
receiving residential services that the
state needs to provide the same or
comparable protections as are available
to tenants under our state's landlord
and tenant law and that includes the
protections that we provide for tenants
with
um
from eviction tenants with disabilities
and tenants who
um you know who may have challenging
behaviors
so
the state has not made any changes since
the last meeting and continues to Excuse
me yes that have you seen their
corrective action request they're
they're corrected uh there was one I
think that they made in April is there
another one that followed between the
May meeting and today yes
they did not send that to me is there no
no there's not another one
well this is different than the one we
had at the June meet at the May meeting
it's it's amending it's it's shoppy no I
mean for example on it says notice of
the resident's right to remain in their
residence rather than the right to
continued Services which is a lot
clearer and ex and I think that had been
made actually excuse me before the May
meeting
it wasn't shown to us at the May meeting
it's not what we discussed at the May
meeting
unless I'm exceedingly confused
which is possible would you like to hear
from this the department about that
first and then well anyway is this the
version that you are concerned about
this this is the version I'm concerned
about because what it does not do is
provide pre-eviction due process
protections for people with
developmental or brain disabilities or
brain injuries who have allegedly
engaged in certain types of behaviors
involving property damage or bodily harm
and you have to keep in mind these are
allegations only and in the private
landlord-tenant context when a private
landlord is faced with a tenant who
allegedly has engaged in behaviors which
might be involving property damage or
even causing harm or placing some other
tenant at risk those tenants are
entitled to Due Process a hearing before
an impartial judge in court who would
make the determination about whether the
landlord met their responsibility their
burden of proof to sustain an eviction
and in
and that is a really important right
that all tenants in this state have
but it's carved out from these rules and
as I explained earlier the Federal Law
requires the state to provide comparable
protections if those protections are not
available under state law so New
Hampshire state law land Lieutenant law
does exclude these kinds of housing
programs from our state law so now we're
in comparable land right we have to
provide comparable protections
but comparable includes due process
pre-deprivation okay well this version
that I'm looking at
says that in the case where they have
a
serious sort of bodily Farm except for
shall provide 72 hours before the
termination and inform the resident this
notice is not an order requiring for the
vacate and include the rights of resin
to appeal the provider's decision to
terminate The Residency agreement and if
it ended there it would be perfect the
problem is that if you look further in
the regs too I think it's Section 3 10
12. it it excludes those two kinds of
situations from pre-deprivation due
process
so those residents can stay in the
residence for three more days and then
they will receive a second notice so a
total of six days and at the end of
those six days they can file an appeal
but they are kicked out of the residence
and that's the problem because they can
file an appeal but they've already lost
their housing
yes represent Broda please
thank you so at the LA I wasn't here at
the last meeting but I did get an update
and did you did you ex discuss this at
the last meeting in May specifically yes
okay and I was under the impression
based on what was said that those things
would be considered and brought to us
today yeah so but the department that it
goes on to say in
you know
shall vacate within three business days
unless the resident files a notice of
intent to to reconsider or essentially
it files an appeal
so but but if you let me just pull out
the rule I had it right there and while
you're doing that if I could have a
follow-up so I would like to ask the
staff
are you saying then therefore the things
that were brought up that we expected a
revision to include or at least consider
was not is not here
he's not in our package
um the the conditional approval from May
12 2023 is the last conditional approval
at the last meeting the department was
asked to give a
um
analysis of how other states
did this yes which they did um send to
us
and um the problem with that is that
although it is interesting information
um it's not relevant to
how New Hampshire does the rules
um so that's that's why I didn't talk
about it it just I mean it tells you
what some of the other states do I think
the problem here is the
the definition of of comparable because
comparable means similar so the question
almost is becoming a policy question is
this a similar program to the Federal
or not and I can't answer that for you
and then my last question yeah please
there is in the in the part that
representative chair Maguire is talking
about it's uh C4 I don't know exactly
what page it's on but there's an edit
about from OLS to The Simpsons it's a
grim it's really a grammatical comment
but am I to understand that this part
where it says in the cases where the
behavior of the resident poses a serious
threat of bodily harm
this part is not changed that your
comment is just strictly editorial
that is correct okay
and and to answer your question chair if
you if you notice um what you are
referring to is on page 20 I have it in
front of me yeah so C4
indicates that
um and when you're reading include the
rights of the resident to appeal in
accordance with
310.12 below so then if you flip over to
page 22
um and you look at it's I'm 3 10 12
paragraph D it provides that
um if the hearing is requested the
provider shall continue to provide the
residential services until a decision is
rendered and here's where the problem
lies unless the reason for termination
is the behavior of the resident posing a
serious threat of bodily harm
or substantial damage
so that's that's the carve out so in
those instances they've removed the
right to pre-eviction due process
and I think the committee was really
concerned that
allowing this to proceed besides the
fact that it conflicts with what the
Federal Law requires the state to do is
that it could put vulnerable individuals
at Great risk of homelessness because
although the department added a
provision for an emergency team meeting
to occur there's not an assurance that
the person would be provided with
suitable alternative housing before they
could be evicted
so I think that was in part why folks in
the committee wanted to work wondering
what other states did Even though like I
said it's it's not really relevant
because the what the Federal Law
requires is for states to look at their
own landlord tenant laws and provide
comparable protections as are afforded
to tenants under their own landlord
tenant laws
does that help
okay thank you very much thank you so
much for your time
thank you
foreign
good morning again for the record my
name is Melissa Nemeth with the
Department of Health and Human Services
so the I think um attorney yuniz said it
well and that we're looking at the
definition of the word comparable and
that does not mean 100 equal so in in
this case what the state has tried to do
is say well the landlord tenant laws
don't apply what can we do that is most
closely aligned for these individuals
and the
request for the team meeting that was
just brought up so that is on page 20 of
the conditional approval request
um it's paragraph five on that page that
provides for if an individual is given
this notice that their provider intends
to terminate their agreement within 72
hours
that goes out to the members of their
team and they have to immediately
convene a team meeting within 24 hours
and determine and take the appropriate
course of action to ensure that the
resident
ensure their health and safety and also
ensure that the resident has access to
an alternative safe residence and
actually the state feels this is more
protective than the landlord tenant law
because in in ordinary landlord tenant
law there isn't a team of folks around
you to help support you and find
something else and the state's goal here
is to absolutely ensure that people are
not rendered homeless and now they still
do have the right to appeal so they
might be placed in an alternative
residence while that appeal is pending
but they will still they're not losing
that right to the appeal so that
appeal could you know turn out in a
whole different way but in the in that
interim period there is access to an
alternative for them
so as a result of the last meeting in
May
your pal your policy didn't change
because you felt that you had already
addressed that
that's correct
in the the changes that you've seen now
there's in that paragraph that I'm
talking about there are a couple of
track changes you will see there that
was based on testimony in the April
hearing so we the changes that were made
that are reflected here were as a result
of those conversations that took place
in April
at the May meeting the only as I was
pointed out the only requests of the
department was to look and see and
provide an analysis as it were as to how
other states do this
so
there was concern on the by the Kimmy by
the committee that
these
this this policy that was presented in
May wasn't enough
and he
what was done to
confirm that or analyze that or address
that
I mean the Department's position really
didn't change we've taken a look and
feel that this is the most appropriate
thing to do for the folks here in New
Hampshire to make sure that they if they
are engaging in these behaviors and need
to leave their residents that they have
access to another residence in an
appropriate amount of time and they
would have their meeting within 24 hours
of getting that notice to ensure they
have somewhere safe and appropriate to
go
this is in fact better than the original
proposal because it does specifically
say that the T the meeting will
make ensure they have a safe place to go
which
I know that last month I was looking at
the original proposal not the corrective
action or the conditional approval
request
anyone else have a question yes please
representative Lynn so you know I'm just
wondering
I understand what you're saying is that
that you think this is I guess
I'm just curious
what would be the problem of of require
of all of providing that the person can
remain pending the results of the appeal
I mean it sounds like the appeal it
sounds like it all has to happen very
quickly
a part of the department is that even
though that is sort of a condensed uh
you know as you mentioned it goes kind
of quickly is that if someone's Behavior
has gotten to that point it could still
be risky not only to them but to the
provider and to the other residents in
the home and as I had mentioned the last
time the department is kind of looking
at the whole picture where we also have
an obligation to protect the other
people in that residence so this is
trying to strike a balance between to
try to keep everybody safe and get
everybody in the appropriate setting and
get them the appropriate services that
they need
all right thank you
Madam chair yes Senator
um would it be appropriate for me to ask
what ensuring
um
access to housing looks like
I think it can look very different
depending on the situation so that's
sort of a hard uh question to answer but
I had mentioned the last time that
um you know it's it's no surprise that
in New Hampshire for these folks as well
as you know the rest of the general
population there are housing shortages
and things of that nature in some
instances it might mean and this would
be you know not the ideal it could mean
that they go to a hotel but have staff
supporting them while something can be
found in some instances there might be a
respite home that has an opening or
provider that can be found that would
provide these services on a number
emergency basis while the team is still
figuring out it may be that this is an
interim step and looking for another
long-term alternative might take some
time but those are some of what might
happen in the interim
Facebook
okay do we have a motion
I'll make the motion and I can if
there's a second I'd like to speak to it
okay I'll I'll offer the second all
right what representative lamb what is
your motion by the way pardon what is
your emotion I'm sorry my motion is to
approve all right thank you and I I
guess I would say this I think that uh
Miss Rosenberg raises a very raises
valid points but
I think the response at least satisfies
me in in this sense first of all and
this may be just simply be my uh my not
being as as thorough as I should have
but I did not realize this I think maybe
I was reading the same mistaken thing
that you were Madam chair but I did not
realize that there although there is no
pre-deprivation hearing
um or at least may not they may not be
in in the circumstances that Ms
Rosenberg uh mentioned there it the I'm
satisfied from what this what the
department have said is that there will
not be
the person will not be left homeless so
there is a post deprivation hearing that
is guaranteed
um and the uh the the person also in
that interim time is not going to be
left homeless and I think that while
that is that may not be exactly the same
as would be the the case under the
state's landlord tenant law it it seems
to me that it is comparable and and the
other thing that I would point out is it
seems to me that in both the landlord
tenant scenario and this scenario
the the alternative for for the the
owner of the property of ins in a
situation that really becomes an
emergency is to call the police and have
the person arrested and it seems to me
that particularly in this circumstance
that's something that should be avoided
if if it if at all possible and uh it
seems to me that that the the way the
the option that is is provided under the
regulation as proposed that is you have
to leave but we're not going to leave
you homeless and you will get a post
deprivation hearing uh tens to tends to
provide an alternative that will not be
result in the person being arrested
which I think is is kind of in
everybody's interest so for those
reasons while I understand Ms
rosenberg's concern and and uh it's
certainly a well taken concern I I I'm
satisfied with the state with the
Department's response so that's why I
support it
thank you
representative Schmidt or representative
thank you madam chair well again we're
talking about a difficult situation here
right where we're trying to balance
risks to both parties uh rights of both
parties and so forth uh and I think this
is a reasonable uh modality on the part
of the department to try to get again
something that seems reasonable and
we'll have to see whether uh whether
this does the trick so I I think we need
to move forward at this point
representative
I am concerned about this because
um it says ensure that the resident has
access to an alternative safe residence
but
who defines and who understands what the
safe residence is who determines that
the department what if the person
doesn't feel safe in that environment
feel safe in their previous environment
so I don't know how to
and maybe we can't you know
we can't Define it more than that but
maybe you can help me with that
I'd be happy to so in that provision
where it calls for the service
coordinator to convene a team meeting
the individual that is affected by this
is part of that team if they had a
guardian they would be part of that team
their service coordinator and all of
their providers that are appropriate
would be there so it would be a decision
that is reached jointly
okay and where would I find that
so the members of the that the
individual is part of the team or their
Guardian is so it says a service
coordinator or designee immediately
convenes a team meeting
um that would be the individual would be
part of that they're part of the team I
guess it's not you won't find a
definition in this rule of what team is
okay um but it I think that to the
individuals with all the other rights
that are explained to them I think it
would be known to them who the members
of the team are and and in any service
planning meeting it's a requirement um
based on other rules that the individual
be there and in fact they are the uh
this is an individual driven Service
delivery system so they would be driving
those conversations in large part
okay thank you I I'm satisfied okay any
other comments or questions
representative Leon
um thank you madam chair
um I I just want to refresh my
understanding of that this this is
situations where these people are housed
with other people with similar similar
needs and so it's a shared living
arrangement in some way yes that's
correct thank you given that and given
the balance of the rights of both these
people and those others who are living
with them I'd love to have more
solutions but I think right now this
makes sense to move forward okay thank
you anyone else
in favor
aye opposed
all right thank you represent Senator
Ward as voted no
all right
thank you
all right Department of Safety
okay um 2022 159 the driver license
rules um the proposed rules provide
procedures and licensing requirements
for the issuance of all classes of
driver's license and non-driver
identification cards the rules in the
forms are being amended to address some
recent statutory changes and program
changes a conditional approval request
has been filed and there are only two
issues remaining in the rule although
you'll see a lot of comments throughout
but those are around the forms so I'll
take the easier the two topics to deal
with first and that would be on page 52
of the conditional approval request
um
here that section is about false
statements made during an official
proceeding and the scope of the hearing
about the respondent's false statement
the rule says that the scope of the
hearing will determine whether the
respondent's false statement was made
because the person reasonably felt
coerced
into making the statement or whether
they reasonably believed the false
statement was true
and you can see I've flagged the word
reasonably and it is a legal standard
the department says that the hearing
officer will most likely use the legal
standard when determining reasonableness
but they don't want to Define it here in
the rule because they're concerned about
some unintended consequences and I think
that's understandable because it's
probably going to involve some case law
and
um you know so that application so they
it makes sense to me not to Define it
here but you may have some questions to
ask the agency before I get into the
bigger issue around the forms are there
any questions
I don't see any so let's dive into the
mess in the form sure so
um like I said this is going to cover
the rest of the comments made throughout
the rule and I'm going to talk about
this at a very high level so in February
of last year the department was asked by
the committee to develop a policy around
making sure that their forms were
updated or not updated outside of the
rulemaking process because at that time
they had a proposal that had some forms
that were updated outside of formal
roommaking
so the department did enact that policy
but there are forms in this proposal
that updates were made outside of
rulemaking and that was prior to the
implementation of this policy
so as the department brings proposals
forward we may encounter this issue
again
so
um the proposals there are a lot of
forms in in the proposal and I wasn't
going to go through each one since we
have a lot on the agenda today there are
12 forms in the proposal and they all
had amendments outside of rulemaking
most were editorial there were only two
that had substantive changes and those
changes were around the insertion of
real ID requirements additionally there
are two forms that had some requirements
incorporated into interim rules and then
those interim rules expired
but it looks like that only some of the
sections of the forms expired and not
the entire form for example one of the
forms included a certification statement
and that was in the interim Rule and
that expired another form had some
questions about the individuals such as
gender and physical attributes but those
requirements are actually in the statute
so they're probably okay
but anyway that's a high level view of
the comments around the forums like I
said it didn't want to go through each
and every one if the committee wants to
do that we can but um but you may have
some questions for the Department around
the policy of making sure that forms are
only updated if they're going to be
updated substantively through the the
rulemaking process
what you're doing about
good morning I'm attorney Dave Hills
from the Department of Safety
um so as it's been explained we did
enact the policy at the request of this
committee to address
the process of amending forms by the by
the agency and as the community attorney
explained
um
you know the the reality is is that this
department has a lot of rules uh their
10-year rules and so you know there's
likely to be many examples that were
committed in the past of having done the
same activity and they're only going to
keep coming to light as the rules have
been brought forward
um the decision has not been made
um by the department to allocate
resources to uh
thoroughly go back and revisit every
rule set they have to you know correct
this
as a targeted exercise but basically as
the rules Come forward for re-adoption
that we would take care of this issue
um you know otherwise the department
intends to you know implement the policy
that
um that we enacted at the committee's
request last February
I am absolutely shocked and it took you
until 2022 to realize that your forms
are rules and they have the effect of
Law and did you ought to control who
make can make changes to them this is
not a new problem in the department of
safety you've been making changes to
those forms without
without any controls for at least
six seven years that I can remember and
I'm not really involved with the
department and I'm very disappointed
that you're now saying oh yes from now
on will be good because I frankly don't
really believe you
I'm happy to take any of the questions
that you have
okay
are there any other questions
okay yes representative Leon um thank
you madam chair thank you for taking
this question if there are forums that
are found to be not consistent with
current practice or not consistent with
the underlying statutes how would those
be brought forward in order to have a
correction especially if those remain
outside of the gel Authority
thank you for your question
um
so taking this rulemaking as an example
um you know when the 1000 rules came up
for read option because they were due to
expire in 2012.
um
reconciling forms to rules were part was
part of the review of re-adopting the
chapter and as I stated before it's not
been the decision of the department to
make a separate project of going back to
I don't know how many rules we have like
maybe 80
um rule chapters to go back as a result
of the implementation of the policy in
February of last year to address all of
these issues outside of the regular
readoption of rules that we would as a
resource allocation issue take care of
this as the different chapters came up
for read option I hope that answers your
question I'd like to ask what controls
do you have in place to ensure that
going forward no form will ever be
changed without going through rule
making so so the control that we have is
that we implemented the policy that was
requested by the committee last year
which was implemented in February of
2022. before that we did not have a
policy and what does that policy do
um I apologize that I don't have a copy
of the policy with me it was provided to
the committee when it was enacted to
demonstrate that we complied with that
to my recollection what the policy says
is that agency Personnel at the you know
sort of lower uh levels that would be
involved in rulemaking if they want to
um make changes to the form that it goes
to the legal unit in order to ensure
that
um you know whatever rulemaking is
actually required you know by the change
you know say for example it's not just a
rearrangement of of the information on
the form without changing anything which
would as I understand it'd be completely
outside of rulemaking
but to make sure that if there's any
changes that the agency wants to make
that the legal unit would identify that
any necessary rulemaking is is done
see representative Leon and
representative Lynn
um thank you madam chair
um
I I do have some questions because last
summer there were constituents who had
forms who were told that they needed to
surrender the physical copy of their
driver's license when they had a
suspended license and they had a form
from your department that said that that
needed to happen when they received it
back from the court when the court told
them that it was not necessary and they
went to the DMV and conquered they were
told by the people working the desk that
that form was not correct and it wasn't
in force and don't worry it doesn't
actually matter what procedures do you
have in place so that your Frontline
employees may know that a forum is
incorrect but uh the rulemaking body
needs to be informed by that
yeah
lovely
um thank you for your question
um I honestly don't have an answer for
you today on that I wasn't involved in
that I feel like I should find out some
information for you about
that instance and then basically work
from there about how the policy would
apply to a situation like that and I can
provide that information back to the
committee
thank you please do representative Lynn
yeah I wonder if I could just follow up
and I and I recognized that this may
that you know I'm I'm sort of this is
coming out of the blue in a sense and so
you may not have an answer to this
specific
but I'm just wondering when if
when you say you didn't go you know the
department hasn't sort of gone back to
make
to kind of redo things that forms that
are maybe in existence from the past the
where there hasn't been some particular
reason to do so
I assume that if
if a court has said there's a problem
with either a regulation or a form uh
and it's and it's invalid or needs to be
changed for one reason or another I
assume I assume that the department then
makes the change
thank you for your question
um I don't have knowledge of a of an
instance of when a court has issued an
order to that effect so that we would
need to comply with it but it's my
belief that if we were the recipient of
a court order that explicitly said
something like that that we would
implement the Court's order okay well
let me then let me be specific and maybe
if you're you know while you're checking
on things maybe you could sort of check
it I can recall and this is this
actually goes back a number of years now
but sometime within say the last
10 years maybe maybe less than that it
may be eight years
the the Supreme Court issued a decision
saying that the Departments
rules and form regarding
when someone who was from out of state
but wanted to get a um wanted to get a
New Hampshire pistol permit
um which although it's not required
still is an available thing
the Supreme Court said that the that the
Department's rules and the forms that
they were using were invalid
um and they did not comply with New
Hampshire law
and and reversed and that was a this was
a person from New Jersey who had applied
the court reversed the Department's
denial of his permit and I'm just
wondering whether or not that um
the department changed its rules and uh
and forms in response to that and so if
you know if you're going to be checking
on other things I wonder if you could
check on that and let us know
I will definitely thank you you're
welcome
any other questions
I had no other issues ma'am
foreign
does someone have emotion
is it possible to make a motion to
conditionally approve with the
understanding that the answer is there
the questions that we have today will be
answered
yes certainly yes
yeah they have filed the conditional
approval request and um in the letter I
can include that
um that they want that the committee
wants to report back on those issues
yes
any further discussion I'm
with that motion my understanding is
that this will be at the next meeting on
the agenda the next meeting and that
information that report will be given to
us by then
well they have a what 30 days to return
their conditional approval response and
so it wouldn't necessarily be on the
next agenda but we should receive their
response in their letter probably before
the next agenda and so we can present
that information to you at that time
um representative groda with a
conditional approval request if the
committee approves it the agency then
does a conditional approval response it
goes only to staff and uh so long as the
two documents are exactly the same then
we tell the agency that they can go
ahead and adopt if their response
differs from substantively from the
conditional approval requests then it's
automatically becomes a preliminary
objection and would come back to the
committee
so then how do we address the caveat
that I have that depends on the that we
receive this report and that the report
that we receive is one that we
that addresses the concerns that we have
based on the committee's motion the
department would be obligated to come
back and present a report on it but the
rule would have already been taken care
of
so I just want to make sure that the
committee is comfortable with that so
yes
that is our procedure Madam chairman
attorney Hills yes oh thank you very
much
um I have um director John marasco from
the DMV I'm here today and um if the
committee believes it's you know proper
he'd like to make a statement about
what's been discussed here today
uh I'm delighted to hear from because
that's relevant to these rules I however
have broad concerns about forms
throughout the department of safety and
how they are controlled but I'd love to
hear how the DMV is doing it thank you
seeing that's where most people get to
interface with the Department of Safety
good morning Madam chair members of the
committee thank you so much for giving
me just a moment here
um I'd like to thank attorney hilts and
administrator Mike Mercier for being
here this morning
um so I've been in this position for
approximately 15 months and I'm
listening to the conversation here and I
just wanted to get to this table for a
minute when I came in 15 months ago one
of the things I learned when I first
became the DMV director was the
importance of the rule sets that we have
that govern the agency we have many of
them they're very complex and I learned
very quickly that that is law
whatever is in the rule is law period so
any changes to forms any changes at all
need to go through this committee and so
what I want you to know is right up
front I fully understand that respect
that and we're going to conform to that
um
any rule changes or or changes to forms
in the last 15 months the only changes
that have happened under my tenure there
have been the name change at the top of
the document which we did run through
Department of Safety legal
because it's not a substantial change to
information in the document but it
doesn't make sense to continue putting
out correspondence to the public that
has
passed information or outdated
information on it
as far as moving forward
what I can tell you is that from a
training standpoint we are working very
hard in the division to get to a level
of gold uh standard training and
actually I'll share with the committee I
just had a conversation with
um a representative from amva the
American Association of Motor Vehicle
administrators late last night and on
July 31st AMV is actually coming to New
Hampshire as part of a pilot program to
train up to 100 DMV employees on what
anva offers best practices standards as
well as leadership training for
hopefully all of our leaders within the
organization there's a pilot program for
amva they're starting with New Hampshire
because we we asked if we could partner
with them that's the type of training
that we're bringing in so I just want to
let you know that we're going to be
focused on uniform messaging at all of
our counters around the state we have 14
locations approximately 60 counters a
lot of employees and that's got to be
tightened up and we have been working on
that the other thing is with DMV forms
and Waters I also identified when I
first came in that many of them the
terminology is not clear we have a lot
of we get roughly 400 000 phone calls a
year that come into the agency many of
those are generated because of our
letters and forms they go out people
don't understand what they mean they're
not grammatically correct so
we had talked about uh and we we had one
about a year ago within the organization
a small Committee of employees that were
actually working to update our forms and
review our letters but with the tasks
that we have there and the complex
operation it falls off and then it comes
back we actually just this week had a
conversation about a part-time program
specialist three position that would be
able to do that review DMV policies get
them to where they need to be and review
all of our letters and forms and make
sure that they're where they need to be
so those are those are some of the
things that we're working on internally
I just wanted you to hear that what I
can assure you is this that during my
time as the MV director there will be no
changes to any forms or anything that
would violate the rule set that would
need to go through jail car it will not
happen it will not happen in I
appreciate attorney hilts shouldering
this and trying to get everything over
the finish line and and representative
Lynn if you'd like we will do a deep
dive we will do a deep dive on other
forums that might be out there we'll put
together a committee of employees work
with DOs legal and we'll find out other
forms that need to be brought forward to
this committee well before the 10-year
Mark whatever you need us to do we'll do
it
I'm happy to take any questions thank
you are there any questions
representative Leon um thank you madam
chair and thank you director for being
here
um when a person has a suspended license
do they need to surrender that copy of
their license that they hold within five
days of having that license suspended so
this has come up and I I am going to ask
administrator mercio to field that
question it came to my attention several
months ago through financial
responsibility that licenses were still
being sent in and yet we weren't uh
anticipating that and didn't need them
any longer and I I do want to if I could
defer to Mike that's right we don't we
don't need the licenses we should not be
receiving the licenses okay thank you
then there's uh error in the rules that
have been submitted because
um on page 53 on on rule 10 16 15.
um it speaks about how if the person has
failed or refuse to comply with um the
order to mail or deliver the suspended
or revoked item to the department within
five working days basically that they
won't be getting their license back
so if there is no need to surrender then
this is an error in the rules that we
are looking to approve
thank you um could you cite the rule uh
section for me please the section is
1016.15. refuse a little surrender
articles and this would be C1
because the forums state that it needs
to be returned within five working days
and it does not specify any orders thank
you
so minimum chair based on that I'd like
to
we didn't we didn't vote on the motion
right to have haven't had a motion I
thought we had a motion oh yes with
that's what I'd like to withdraw my
motion because I don't want to
conditionally improve something that's
got an error in it
uh yes we should be uh
require representative Lynn to withdraw
a second if he wanted to so you're
withdrawing your motion entirely
okay could I just raise one question I
want I want to make sure that
that I'm
that I'm understanding is correct that's
the it
it sounded like
the rule that the section you read said
if the person doesn't
comply with a request to surrender the
license then certain bad things happen
and I guess what I'm wondering is is
that really
if I'm understanding what was just said
that really may not be inconsistent with
what was just said in the sense that if
the state is no longer saying you have
to submit you have to surrender your
license then that provision may be
superb Superfluous but it's not sort of
wrong that's that's am I correct on that
in other words if the if the department
is simply not going to be saying asking
people surrender the physical license
then
that provision might
you know maybe it's unnecessary but I'm
not sure that it's wrong
no I'm sure yes I was going to ask the
same Quest or or make the same comment
as uh representative Lynn it does seem
to me that it isn't saying that this
will happen it's saying if something is
required and doesn't happen
there will be consequences
what is the citation again
it's on page 54 and it's 10 16.15
refusal to surrender articles ended
section c one and two I believe
oh yes here we go okay
that that seems like a correct
interpretation
um because an a uh it's talking about a
person's failure to refuse to comply
with an order to return so if the order
is not given then the trigger won't
happen
okay thank you representative Leon
thank you
I still remain concerned because I had a
constituent who was told by the courts
that they needed to return it and then
the DMV told them that they was not
necessary
I'm just concerned about the forms um I
guess maybe we deal with this in a
different way but I these are people who
are undergoing a pretty severe change in
their life when their license is
suspended I want to make sure that our
roles and our forms aren't making their
life more difficult than it already is
due to their most likely bad decision
uh I'm concerned that the court ordered
them to do something and then the DMV
said oh don't bother
that appears to be incorrect behavior on
somebody's part something's wrong yes
really
so
anyone have emotion although
well we can move to accept it we can
come up with a correction and
conditionally approve we can so make a
permanent objection so you know I guess
I
I appreciate what everybody has said but
I'm I I'm guess I'm going to make a
motion to approve
um and if there's a second I'd I'd like
to speak speak to the motion I'll second
that okay representative Lynn so I guess
what um I'm sorry is that motion to
conditionally approve with extra
information with the with yes the same
conditions that that were previously
stated by it by my colleague
um and I guess what I was going to say
is that if this um
it
although it seems like this one section
might generally be superfluous
I'm it strikes me that there could be
circumstances in which the department
would issue an order to somebody to
surrender the license for again I'm just
I'm sort of you know just trying to
think of an example here but suppose the
department had some information
suggesting that the person that they're
talking about was was misusing the
physical license was somehow using it to
you know to assist in making copies for
for somebody else or something like I
mean I could imagine a circumstance in
which the department would say we do
want you to return the license and if
you hadn't done that that might be a
that might be another reason to uh to
impose some consequences again that I'm
I you know that seems like it might be a
uh not anyway a typical example but
all I'm saying is I could see
circumstances in which that provision
would make sense and in most cases where
it seems like it's just Superfluous so
you know I don't
to the extent that we have some that
there's a need to approve these rules I
I would not let this stop
stop us from doing so
representative but this but that's in
that ambiguity
is sort of identify the problems that we
have right now with
with forms and
things not aligning
so what we just causing
more difficulty by
I guess I I would tend to say I would
tend to say not because I'm not sure
this is a this is simply a a provision
that says
if we order you to do something and you
don't do it then certain things happen
and
I think that the answer in the
run-of-the-mill case will be there
simply not going to be ordering people
to do something so if they don't
um you know
but I I see your point I see your point
I'm just you know I guess part of this
is what
how crucial is it that we act today
well this has been postponed and our
deadline is a week out I'm not Senator
thank you
um thank you madam chair I I would agree
that if we this is here and it allows
for certain actions to be taken if we
were to remove it or suggest that they
remove it and then it comes up that uh
it is in fact necessary to have this in
or circumstances arise where it's needed
and it has been taken out we may find
ourselves right back together with an
even greater mass
any further comments represent well I
guess as long as we get the report which
helps okay right yes
right so if we could have the motion
again please
it was a motion to could accept the
conditional approval and to um come back
to with a report on
um some extra information about forms
and um
some case law I believe
and the implementation of their policy I
believe to
okay
oops attorney Hills thank you um I just
want to clarify I but by you saying case
law I'm thinking of the comments by
representative Lynn that ref okay that
referenced the issue with the pistol
permit so correct okay thank you okay
so that's the motion to conditionally
approve any further comments
those in favor
I opposed
thank you and I'm looking forward to
receiving those reports at your earliest
convenience
and thank you director barrasso very
much for your statement I think that's
very heartening to hear thank you
representative I agree for sure yes
definitely thank you thank you everyone
okay Motor Carrier safety rules
yes so uh 2022 186 on the motor carrier
safety rules currently before the
committee is a conditional approval
request that was submitted prior to the
May meeting
um this item was postponed so that the
department would have an opportunity to
provide further information regarding
the dates of the Federal Regulations
being Incorporated by reference when
um and when the particular document
that's being Incorporated was last
updated
good morning attorney Dave Hills from
the Department of Safety
um
what I discovered in answer to the
committee's questions
um is in looking at the federal
government's website on the code of
federal regulations
um the current uh the most current
version of the applicable cfrs would be
the 2022 version
and as I've been able to tell it they
have a utility on their website that
allows you to identify changes between
two different versions and I've
discovered that there were some changes
to the applicable chapters of the CFR
that were made in 2021
um so I know that last meeting there was
some anecdotal information provided to
the committee where you know I asked one
person sort of on the fly like how often
do things change and I got you know
about maybe every three to four years
back but and doing research on the code
of federal regulations website I learned
that there were actually changes done
last year so to speak
um I hope that answers the committee's
questions
all right
um I have a
have a question if it changes annually
is that any reason you shouldn't be able
to put the current relevant version in
your rules
thank you for your question
um I do on behalf of the department I do
believe that it is an unnecessary
hardship for the committee for the
Department to need to come in every year
to respond to changes in the in the
federal code of regulations
um as the chair pointed out there is a
new addition to the applicable cfrs
every year in the range where title 49
is for these motor carriers it's updated
annually every October
and according to their website
um you know even if there is no change
from any particular year to year they
will issue uh you know
cover you know a jacket cover to
basically say here's your new 2022 but
um you I guess theoretically can put
that on your old cfrs and that'll be the
current one
um you know it
I I don't expect that it would be the
case at all that if there were say a
substantive change in 2019 and then no
substantive change in 20 if the
department were asked well what version
are you implementing we're not going to
say well we're going to pass on the 20
because there was no change we're going
to still do the 19 and again the next
year if there's no change in 21 we're
not going to say well we're going to
stick with the 19 because nothing's
changed you know the answer is we
implement the most current we enforce
the most current regulation every year
even if nothing changed from the year
before I hope that answers the
committee's question
okay any other questions comments or
concerns
there were no staff comments on this
says I recall uh no the conditional
approval request turned all the
substantive comments into just
informational notes to the committee
and it's someone of emotion move to
approve second
okay by representative Lynn seconded by
representative Schmidt any discussion
all right those in favor
aye
opposed I arnay
and the motion rule is approved
thank you
all right the next one is
um
uh the office of a licensed Allied
health professionals it's uh 2022 165
and it's actually um it's now a consent
excuse me the department sent or the
board sent um a conditional approval I
just and and everything is fine now I
just wanted to note to the agency and to
jailcar that this proposal now cites to
another proposal so this cannot be
um adopted until the other one is
adopted which is 20 23 52.
um but it is all correct and it fixes
the problems that they had
and is 52 is since 52 is on our calendar
could we just move this down afterwards
please
um it's just a note to to gel car
because they won't adopt they just won't
adopt the this before the other proposal
okay well in that case so the the rule
is fine
yeah uh I happen to remember that in
House Bill 2 we repealed the Allied
Health Board uh is that going to affect
this rule very significantly
so the board has not met Tina Kelly
um program specialist office of
professional licensure and certification
um House Bill 2 has not been signed yet
the board has not met in order to be
able to withdraw this so my anticipation
is
this is probably going to be the last
time you see this we'll have to put
something forward that says because
House Bill 2 was signed we're
withdrawing anything associated with
that board
uh would it save us trouble if we just
postponed it until after Hospital you
could do that yes fine I moved to do so
second oh
those in favor
aye
okay thank you well we don't want to to
exercise you unnecessarily there's
enough necessary exercise going on at
the moment
all right so we will put we'll postpone
this until uh
we need a waiver on that yes we will
okay our next regular meeting and we
will request a waiver if that's okay
director moral okay press pause yes
that's fine
thank you sense doing exercises all
right
tax and land Appeals
so 2022
197 is on the procedural rules for
specific types of appeals there was a
conditional approval filed that
addressed all the comments with regards
to discrepancies between the rule text
and the forms however there are a couple
additional substantive comments that
remain a number of which were actually
made the last time this rule came before
the committee
the first comment is on page rule page
two of the rule text and is also
reiterated on page three the rule
um
talks about default judgments and says
that non-attendance by the taxpayer or
the taxpayers representative
at a noticed hearing will result in the
dismissal of the appeal unless the
failure is
a failure to appear as excused the
entering of a default judgment or
limiting the opportunity to be present
despite the circumstances May violate
due process and as I stated this comment
was made back in 2013 the last time this
these rules were before the committee
the next comment is on page three it's
an unclear comment
this rule talks about
when the taxpayer will be excused they
have to file notice within 14 days in
order to be excused from a hearing but
that time may be shortened if there is
good cause however there's nothing in
the rules that would
explain what exactly good cause would be
considered in order to get that
um
essentially waiver of the 14 day
deadline
there's another unclear comment on page
three that relates to the comment that
was just talked about with regard to
good cause
the word may is used inappropriately it
should be
shall be shortened if there is good
cause otherwise the board would have
discretion to still deny even if there
is good cause determined
uh the next comment is also on page
three is an unclear comment at the
bottom of the page
with regard to this rule it states that
when a taxpayer does not appear within
30 minutes of the hearing start time
their case will be dismissed or
defaulted however the rule goes on to
say that if a municipality fails to
appear then the board will decide the
case on the hearing and the record
additionally if the municipality
appears before the conclusion of the
hearing they still will be given the
opportunity to be heard this discrepancy
in treatment may be against the public
interest if the committee determines
that this rule treats like entities such
as parties to a hearing differently once
again this comment was made back in 2013
the last time these rules came before
the committee
there's also an unclear comment on pages
20 and 21 regarding
um
the opening statement made by the board
it does not say who gives the statement
on behalf of the board if it's a board
member if it's a representative and once
again that comment was made back in
2013.
all right I'd like to hear from the
agency
thank you good morning Madam chair
members of the committee
um
thank you for the opportunity to come
and explain these um we had a
continuance from the May meeting which
we appreciated because it gave us the
ability to work with the committee
attorney and try to narrow down and make
most of the suggested changes however
attorney Ricard is right these are the
remaining ones so I'll just go through
them one by one some of them are brought
up could you just identify yourself I'm
sorry my name is Ann stelmack I'm the
clerk and the uh or the administrator of
the board
I apologize
so yeah some of these have have come up
before in the past
um but I will start with talking about
um
20205 non-attendance by the taxpayer
uh the board
strives to give anywheres up to six
months notice of hearings
um the board has jurisdiction over at
least 70 taxes some are original
jurisdiction and some are shared with
the Superior Court we have concurrent
jurisdiction oftentimes these cases are
large they take months if not years to
prepare for so we do our best to go over
and above 541 and giving extra notice
um
keeping in mind that this process a lot
of the taxes especially property tax
starts at the local level by the time
they do have a choice where to appeal
they're essentially bringing an action
against the municipality contesting
their assessment what happens is by the
time they get to the board one to two
years later they get their hearing date
we have given them significant notice of
a hearing
but oftentimes and I can count them in
my 22 years a handful of times people
some people have gotten tired of waiting
that long and they just don't show up
after the municipality has gone to Great
expense to prepare and pay for
Consultants appraisals those are very
pricey and a taxpayer just doesn't feel
like coming
I believe that this is where
um
we will give 30 minutes A lot of people
you know they're coming down from the
North country or out of state or
whatever so we do allow for for someone
being late but in the end when a
municipality is there with a witness and
they've paid for that at the expense of
other taxpayers and someone chooses not
to show up
um I think the due process argument the
the the end result is we will dismiss it
by decision with a re-hearing paragraph
and if a taxpayer just honestly we've
had it happen a couple times where
taxpayers made a mistake they put their
date on the wrong calendar if they can
specify in the order the decision States
if you can give with specificity why you
missed the hearing and didn't attend
we'll reassign you a new hearing date so
that is also you know there again an
extra protection layer that if they've
truly made a mistake and missed a
hearing date you know and they can state
with specificity the board has always
granted that as long as you know there
there's a good reason
but most people that just don't show up
municipalities can come back and ask for
costs to recover some of those costs for
for a taxpayer just not wanting to be
there I've had people call up from
hospital beds
um people get sick we're fine with
continuances on an emergency basis just
like any Court would be but when
somebody just doesn't
think to call and say you know what I'm
just going to withdraw this case I'm
tired I've waited too long I'm over it
now or whatever and they don't notify
anyone and we're all ready to go and
then just someone doesn't show up
um that rehearing paragraph is their
chance to you know sort of justify why
they didn't come and it works well I can
like I said in my 22 years I can count
them on two hands it doesn't happen
often but that is their remedy so that
would be our response to 20205c
questions
I'm concerned that you don't
um
when you if the
uh
if it's the municipality that doesn't
show
and the taxpayer does show you still go
ahead and hold the hearing
and the reason for that is it is the
taxpayers burden by law it is their case
they're bringing the action
initially when an appeal is filed with
the board the we request the
municipality provide all the documents
as the basis for the assessment their
number is presumed correct unless a
taxpayer can prove that they were
disproportionately assessed or somehow
there's errors
um again in my and I can't say this this
will always be the case but
municipalities
um they have a much better track record
of showing up they want to defend their
number but but it's presumed correct and
it is the taxpayer's burden
um so as long as uh that's not to say if
if the board looks at the municipal
records They always review the file
ahead of time and if they have if
there's more questions than what's in
the file
um they will they you know if if they
don't show up they may opt to reschedule
it if there's more questions for a
municipality but in
um in Practical terms municipalities do
have a great track record of coming
um and again a lot of them will maybe
send contractors
um but the board is well versed in those
same documents coming in in about every
file
um
so that's That's the basis
other questions representative layout um
thank you madam chair and thank you for
being here my question is I'm having
trouble finding that rehearing paragraph
and as I'm reading this it looks to me
like somebody getting into a car
accident on their way wouldn't have an
opportunity if you can point me to that
rehearing paragraph I'd appreciate it
um well the rehearings at 541 we put it
in a in a decision it goes out in every
decision regardless if they're dismissed
or not even on a typical case that the
board here is that every
because of 541 it's in every decision
that we issue
um I I it's not specifically carved out
and ruled because it's in statute
um but I'm new to Del Carr so thank you
I figured I'd rather ask than yeah thank
you okay rep director Morrow
um
following up on representative Leon's
question that 541a does talk about
re-hearings but that is something that
occurs after a decision is made
if the board makes the decision then you
can apply for a re-hearing but usually
the grounds for a re-hearing are very
narrow
I
I didn't look at this rule extensively
so I stand to be corrected by Miss
delmac or Rebecca
but the rule itself seems to talk about
applying 14 days in advance if you
cannot make a hearing that wouldn't
cover somebody that's in an automobile
accident on the way
now I understand what the policy is from
Miss delmach's uh testimony and this is
very rare occurrence that this would
happen but uh technically that procedure
is a rule
I'll leave that to the committee
on thank you um so with that information
would it make sense to put that General
policy that if somebody has a good
reason calling from the hospital better
having a car accident that they have an
authorization for a re-hearing or how
would be the best way to put that good
leniency policy into these rules
um so with regard to that it's certainly
something that could be added to this
particular section that you know should
a taxpayer not attend and is issued a
denial that they will receive a notice
with an opportunity to
present evidence that they were unable
to make it and be issued a re-hearing
that is something that could be created
as a rule to make it explicitly clear
because I agree I think it should be in
the rules okay
however I think um you may need a
preliminary objection if you want some
of these things changed there are a lot
of clarity
um comments on here some of which are
um you know like they use the term good
cause but they don't Define what good
cause is and things like that
um so it may be better to give them that
time to to Really
um fix the issues give them time and
also in the objection specifying the
things that you want change so they know
what exactly they have to address
okay
okay representative Schmidt moves we
preliminary object is there a second
representatively on seconds
okay and
I would say that the clarity comments
from staff and
um expansion of what
it shall be shortened for good cause for
example
would be a something and
and including that procedure in the
rules about the rehearing yes please
definitely
are there any other points that people
want to make sure are included in the
are requested of the agency on their
objection response
I don't see any
any other comments
all right move to preliminary object to
the rule with the requests we had
um
those in favor I I opposed
all right thank you very much
appreciate the clarity
okay
um
2022-237 reading and writing teacher and
prep program
so there's only one comment on this
proposal and you'll see it at the top of
the page of the rule which is uh page
four of your PDF packet
that legislative intent comment is there
because paragraph B expired in 2018
that paragraph makes up most of the
proposals you can see and it contains
the skills competency and knowledge
requirements for reading and writing
teachers and so the committee may have
some questions for the agency about that
expiration of the rule like I said since
2018.
it's been a long five years yes
good morning Steve Appleby division
director Department of Education thank
you for your time this morning we
discovered that this section of the
overall rule had expired late last fall
and began the rulemaking process at that
time
we have 73 individuals who currently
hold this endorsement in our state that
is Reading Writing teacher
we have been started auditing looking to
see if we denied anybody incorrectly
while the rule is expired so far we have
found none
we are more than happy if you want a
table for a month and we'll continue our
research and I can
give you a definite assurance that we
haven't denied somebody but at this time
we don't think we have we've only issued
eight licenses under this endorsement
during that five-year period
okay but
um there is a fee involved
and since I believe that fee is
established by the rule and not by the
statute
we would if we approve this rule I would
request that you uh refund the fee
since you didn't have the authority
collect to collect it
um Julie Shea administrative rules
coordinator
um the fee for the certification is not
in this particular section of the rule
um this is just the requirements for the
certification we actually came to you a
few months ago with all of our fees
um and those were not they were expired
for a few months
um but not during the time that this was
so the fee table is not in this
particular rule for this certification
if that makes sense
okay thank you I'm glad to hear it
if I could add one more Point
um unlike most of our rule sets which
the entire section expires in this
instance it was one paragraph within an
overall rule that expired so the rest of
the rule was still in effect it was just
that one paragraph
so because
so the first paragraph is the education
requirements in all of the things that
would be needed and then B is the
content that would be needed so
what we want to do is ensure that nobody
was denied based on not having that
content standard when the paragraph Was
expired
does someone have a motion
okay
okay move by representative Schmidt
second by representative Lynn any other
comments questions concerns
seeing none those in favor
aye
those opposed all right thank you very
much thank you very much
Board of Medicine
so
2023-18 the definition of medical review
subcommittee access to public records
and draft decisions this is on the
regular agenda because these rules had
expired back on April 12th of 2019 even
though they are 100 rules the reason for
that is because when these rules were
adopted back in
2000 and
um
nine nine thank you I couldn't find that
there uh 2009
um they were approved by the committee
but not pursuant to 541 a13 which meant
that they were eight year rules as
opposed to the non-expiring rules that
100 organizational rules normally are so
that is why these had an expiration date
but the rest of them do not and the only
substantive comment on this rule that I
had is an unclear edit comment and it's
an unclear edit because it could be
changed editorially but if the edit
isn't made it would make it unclear what
exactly the section is referring to
because the title is draft decisions
however uh paragraphs B and C seem to
apply to emergency decisions and final
decisions so it's unclear that those
could be found in that section
good morning Tina Kelly from the office
of professional ice Insurance
certification
um we are playing playing cleanup with
some of these rules
um expecting that they hadn't expired
but they did they would have been
covered under 91a
um the description of medical review
subcommittee is in RSA 329 colon 2 Roman
numeral two B and we will change under
Med
105.03 to board decisions rather than
draft decisions
okay is this affected by any current
legislation I remember something coming
through on the medical review
subcommittee
I'm gonna ask Doug
good morning Douglas elster how general
counsel for the office of professional
licensure and certification as of right
now there is no repeal of that statutory
section
in coming through the pipes but it is an
interesting question
because of the changes to mrsc
okay well we'll uh look so as of now you
don't have it we'll see what happens but
but these rules are in accord are being
cleaned up and adopted and you will fix
that draft decision headers okay thank
you any other questions of
Representative
you would follow up on that because in
the in the um bills
I I think the record should reflect that
uh attorney osterhout uh responded in
the affirmative but by nodding his head
rather than saying yes so the record
should reflect his answer
thank you representative Schmidt
represent grota I just want to make sure
that indeed the medical review
subcommittee will now become a peer
review type of board so if there's
legislation coming forward I presume
they will be changing this rule to agree
with it
correct okay
we haven't yet approved it as I recall
okay any other questions comments or
concerns
all right I presume there's no fees
involved in this section no okay good
um do we have a motion
a second by Senator Ward and further
discussion
those in favor
aye aye opposed
thank you very much thank you
okay
2023-21 certification of assessors
this proposal makes changes to the rules
that govern the certification of
assessors and assessor assistance
uh the agency has filed a conditional
approval request that pretty much
resolves all the issues except for one
and you'll see that on page five of the
conditional approval request
and so here
um that's ASB
305.01 B you'll see that this is a brand
new section in the role that impacts dra
certified property assessor assistance
it looks like these folks are certified
they have to meet certain requirements
in order to be certified or to receive
that certification by the dra and this
new section establishing establishes
continuing education and documentation
requirements on on this on this class of
personnel
specifically it establishes a 10 hour
requirement and then increases that
yearly requirement until it reaches a
total of 50 hours over a five-year
period
however the problem is is that the first
year that this requirement becomes
effective is in 2021
so if you see there it says 10 hours are
required for certifications expiring in
2021 and then 20 hours for
certifications expiring in 2022 and this
looks like it's creating some
retroactive requirements in violation of
the Constitution
the department says that and you should
have a copy in the um the other the FP
packet of
hb1552 from 2022 of last year it does
allow for the granting of an extension
for the retroactive or for the
continuing education requirements for
them to be completed by August 31st of
this year
but the language in the bill doesn't set
up an automatic extension so people have
to ask for that extension in order to
get it and they have to do that by
August 31st of this year
so the committee may have some questions
about the number of individuals impacted
what notification has been done whether
or not anybody has asked for this
extension and like I said that our
requirement is applicable and it ends in
August for that extension
yes
Madam chairman yes just for the
committee's edification FYI Betsy Patton
who is testifying his long-term house a
former long-term House member and did
several stints as chair and vice chair
of Joker right
this is the old stomping grounds this is
good this is Betsy I'm Betsy Patton and
I'm the chairman of the assessing
Standards Board and I hope that my vice
chair Bob Gagnon will be able to explain
exactly what's going on with the uh what
you consider retroactive I just want to
say that we um the previous rules that
we went through started in 2019 and then
of course the pandemic hit and we didn't
see anybody until about 20 or 21 22 and
so after our rules were approved in
October of 21 we found that we had some
outstanding issues and this is uh the
one that that is of a concern to you so
um I'll switch it over to Bob and see
what he has today thank you
uh good afternoon I guess good morning
Robert gagne I'm the vice chair of the
assessing Standards Board I'd like to
address whether this is a retroactive
requirement the rules that were placed
in effect
as of October 21 actually require these
individuals to have 50 hours of
continuing education to recertify
which was not our original intent the
original intent was to be 50 hours on a
five year and that's why we put in place
this this
um
phase in for those
questions so if I understand you
correctly in 2021 you had a requirement
for 50 hours of continuing education
did the assessors whose certification
expired that year
get that education
um several did not and they had to ask
for an extension
and and that wasn't that at the time
that was a new requirement
for this classification the the
assistant now the other two
classifications that require 50 hours
that was not new
um so that's why we're phasing it in the
intent was if you if your renewal
was only one year out
you couldn't have had 50 hours because
you didn't have any requirement prior to
that to have a continuing education so
that's why we put this in it and I
believe there are some individuals who
did ask for an extension
where number one and two here would
apply that they need 10 hours if they
had expired in 21 and 20 hours if they
expired in 22. uh the department I don't
believe the department is here so I
can't answer how many individuals it
affects
um if if I recall from our initial
discussions it was
three for 2021 but I don't know how many
were affected in 2022
I would just like to add if we had um
had this discussion and had put it in
the rules for um October 2021 we
wouldn't have the we wouldn't have the
issue today so
um you can't always use the pandemic as
an excuse but it happened so um I'm
hoping that you will just approve our
rules we're here for questions if you
have any
so if I understand correctly the 20 as
of 2021 your rules required 50 hours and
this is decreasing the requirement
yes because we did not require the
certified property assessor
assistant
to have to have 50 we added those in 21
and then realized that we need to do a
phase in okay thank you
any other questions or representative
Schmidt
my question is whether I have to recuse
myself because I am a member of the
assessing Standards Board as well so can
I vote on this or not
that's entirely up to you as long as you
uh indicate that there's a possible
conflict and make the committee members
aware of it which you did then you may
still vote as long as you're not you're
actually a certified assessing assistant
it's not going to make a difference I
didn't think so but I'd rather ask and
absolutely
um
okay anyone else
I don't like the way it's written as if
it were retroactive but I can understand
your point that you're
essentially forgiving if somebody
uh their their certification expired in
2021 your forgiving 40 hours of their
requirement correct
okay go ahead yeah yes
because that
the fact that the requirement was 50
hours for a year and a half
makes a difference in what you're doing
here I think I I don't quite know how to
do it how to address it in the rule
the 50 hours were for two
classifications of assessors
the Third
classification we added in 21 for 50. so
they did not
they were not required to have any
continuing education until
2021 that's why we phased it in no I I'm
just saying that as of the currently
effective rules they're required to have
50 hours of continuing education and
your wave and they could ask for a delay
and your want to waive some portion of
that continuing education is that
understanding correct yes
yes okay representative so I'm I'm not
sure that I completely understand so I
guess my question is this is there
anybody
that
as if this rule is adopted
is there anybody that was not
required to have any continuing legal
education I'm legal education assessor
education in 2021
or in 2022
that would now be required to have that
continuing education for those years
no they would have been required to have
50 now they're being required to have 10
or 20. I thought you said I I just wanna
I thought you said there were
um there was there was there were three
categories and one category did not have
any continuing education requirement
prior to them adopting the rules in 2021
right prior to 21. okay but you I see
but you did adopt him you did adopt
those rules for that for all three
categories in 2021 yes okay I'm sorry
thank you
okay
um
all right any other questions or
comments
I don't like the way it says it but I
can't object the content
does someone have emotion
representative Lynn moves to approve is
there a second
Senator Chandler
any further discussion
okay those in favor
aye opposed
okay thank you very much thank you thank
you
the time
air related programs
well I I think we're at 20 23 29 the
prevention abatement and control of
mobile source air pollution yep
so um
there's only one thing to talk about and
that's on page four of the um uh final
proposal packet and that's page one of
the rule this proposal re-adopts rules
that regulate emissions from Motor
Vehicles this one substantive comment
requires that um well the comments there
because um it looks like it can't be
uniformly applied and what we mean is
that the rule requires owners of
vehicles to adhere to certain idling
limitations
however it looks like it's not possible
for the agency to uniformly enforce the
idling requirements and thus the rule
may be contrary to public interest
because of that lack of ability to be
able to uniformly enforce the
requirements and this issue has been
presented before to the committee and
the rules were approved despite the
concern
good morning Sharon members of the
committee Mike Fitzgerald I'm the
assistant director of the Resources
Division at the Department of
Environmental Services
um I have a few comments if you please
certainly
um as was mentioned these rules have
been in effect for some some time the
department uh does agree that we have
limited resources uh many other states
that have uh either either statutes or
rules regarding idling of vehicles
uh
their agencies have kind of sort of
ticketing Authority where they could go
out observe a vehicle idling and
issue an issue a ticket we don't have
that Authority here in New Hampshire
um and we would have to put any
any violation of these rules through the
same administrative procedures as we
would put for a violation that a power
plant or or a large Industrial Source
puts into place so
um we we do have limited resources
however these rules are very
um helpful
we receive complaints probably somewhere
between five and ten possibly more
complaints uh a year
from generally neighbors uh or or you
know people who have trucks or school
buses that they keep at their homes and
they might go out and start the truck at
six in the morning and let it sit for an
hour while they have breakfast or
something like that
um and so our uh we we receive
complaints these rules are helpful we
generally can go out and and or make a
phone call and uh
speak to the individual that's
responsible and and remind them that
there are rules and and that these uh
you know they can't continue that
practice and that generally resolves
things we don't we're not forced into
going to uh administrative procedures
and enforcement fines and that sort of
thing second
um we also get calls from municipalities
many states have situations where the
municipalities can enforce these type of
rules where local law enforcement again
that's not the case in New Hampshire
and
um so we do get calls from them uh we
certainly inform them we'll send them a
copy of the rule and then they can go
out and speak to the individual
um where the complaint is and we're
sending their you know Health officer or
whatever and let them know that there is
a state rule that prevents this type of
type of behavior and last
um around schools we uh have had a very
successful program over the past 10
years or so where we have supplied
signage to schools
particularly when parents are queued up
waiting for uh uh school school to get
out or or in the morning to to drop off
students
um and and indicating that idling's not
allowed I will point out that the rules
do allow for idling in certain
situations in which air conditioning and
or or heating is is necessary we do do
allow for certain waivers
during during those periods so we're not
but certainly
schools have we've had a very successful
situation where schools have requested
these signs put them up and it has
significantly reduced idling around the
school schools and
um assisting with the prevention of
Health impacts to students so um I I
don't think that the ability to enforce
is is certainly an issue we agree but we
think these rules are helpful and would
appreciate the committee's Passage
representative lamb um thank you madam
chair and uh thank you for that
information
um looking at this rule um in 110203
C2 that seems to be what you're
referring to it's atop a page two of the
rule about supplying heater air
conditioning necessary for passenger
Comfort right however if that's the case
we should perhaps strike this where that
continues to say that that's for in
those Vehicles intended for commercial
passenger Transportation I do know that
my cars do not cool down sufficiently
for it to be safe for my children in
only five minutes so that is also a
public interest issue if we're not able
to reduce the car temperature to a safe
temperature before putting children in
I don't believe we would object to
making that
change all right thank you other
questions
and that was just to strike the word
commercial
to strike I believe striking the word
commercial would be sufficient
[Music]
passenger transportation is what the
issue is representative Leon you have a
motion yes I moved to would it be a
motion to conditionally accept the rules
with that edit yes so moved
okay seconded by representative Schmidt
comments or questions
okay those in favor
aye opposed
thank you very much
thank you
foreign
20 23 96 is on PLC 1200 these rules
relate to or relative to establishing
the licensing requirements for court
reporters and
um as you are probably aware the court
reporters board was changed to an
Advisory Board to the oplc currently
there are interim rules that are in
effect and they expire
um in July 31st
there are one comment on the records
retention issue which we've talked about
at previous meetings and that's relative
to the filing of the the old boards
records maintaining those files so I
wasn't going to spend any time on that
comment since we've talked about that
before and you're aware of the issue and
I believe there's some legislation to
address that
that said there are two main issues to
talk about and I'll take the easier or
the two first
and that is first on page 21 and 15 of
The Proposal
there are two rule sections here that
talk about that an applicant can appeal
a conditional denial but I don't see
anything in the proposal that describes
when the agency would issue a
conditional denial rather than a
straight out denial I don't see any
criteria around that what the agency
will use to make that determination to
issue that conditional denial and that's
a concern because that can result in an
unfair application of criteria that's
unknown and individuals will not know
how that decision is made and that's
really a violation of 541a and I'll stop
there before we get into the next issue
around fees
so where what is a conditional denial of
licensure
conditional up Douglas Ulster PLC
general counsel forget where I was
um
thank you for the question so
conditional denial licensure would be
one of those sort of gray area issues
there's the objective standards set by
the board in the case of an Advisory
Board in consultation with the board and
the application would come into the lplc
we go through the checklist that you
meet the education the experience but
you end up with those situations where
someone may have say something in their
criminal background check and under 332g
you're only allowed to
um
deny an application under certain
standards it has to be substantially
related that language might actually
change in SB 107 but
those kind of situations may require a
more subject matter expertise point of
view and those are the types of things
we would bring to the board so the oplc
would deny in the first instance but
there wouldn't be an actual denial until
it went to the board the individual
would have an opportunity to explain
that criminal background check in that
history and then depending on the
board's decision either the license
would be approved or an actual final
denial would be issued and then we would
file a denial letter which would have
reasons and an opportunity notification
of the right to appeal that decision so
it's sort of those gray areas subject
matter expertise situations so if I
understand correctly a conditional
[Music]
seek is not sure that the applicant is
qualified and they refer to the board
for technical evaluation correct
yeah but that doesn't appear to be well
defined in the rule
I don't it may not be well defined in
the role I think the rule can't be read
in a vacuum because of uh 655
legislation that's moving forward and
the PLC 200s the PLC 300s and there are
references to other rules that have
already been approved by the gel car in
this role so it might not be here but
the references are to otherwise approved
rules
would seem that um they could insert
some language here that describes that
you know if oplc you know conditionally
denies because they need to consult The
Advisory board that something like that
could be stated in the role they don't
at a high level they don't have to drill
down into every instance of of why yeah
representative Schmidt so and the issue
I think that we're looking at here is
oral rulemaking
and do we have to I'll be clear enough
with regard to whether we have that or
not
I I think I agree that we we are instead
of just bringing conditional denial up
right here you ought to say that an
initial license
may be denied until the board has
reviewed and approved it
and that's what you call a conditional
denial I I need to Define what it is
you're doing
yeah
um I I think certainly that that could
be inserted there we probably need to
check with oblc to make sure that
they're good with inserting that kind of
language there it would go into two
places like I said there are two
sections one on page 15 and then one on
page 21. we do have another issue to get
to on the fees so you might end up
postponing or you might end up doing
something different but just FYI on that
okay well let's we've expressed Our
concern on this one okay so
okay so um the next issue is on the fees
and it impacts another proposal that's
coming up next or
one down on um on the agenda and that's
22 or sorry 20 23 52.
um so as you may recall OLS and the
committee has long considered licensing
fees to be refundable and application
fees to be non-refundable and over the
past six to 12 months there has been a
number of proposals that have been
approved that contain citations to the
fees and PLC 1002 which is
2023-52 which is coming up on the agenda
and those rules have been approved with
the understanding that the fee rules
would be moving forward
but there's some language in those rules
that state application processing fees
are non-refundable as is happening here
in 2023-96
there's also language that states that
those fees are non-refundable if the
applicant withdrawals or abandons the
application
when you're in when you review the
language in 2020 352 you will see that
the agency is equating licensing fees
and application fees
so um you should have in front of you a
hard copy packet and we thought that
would be a little easier to review
instead of flipping back and forth
between
96 and 52 if you will
um and so you're going to want to take a
look at that if you look at the first
page here you'll see this is Page 4 of
96 and you'll see that it says an
application processing fee of 155
dollars
um the IP had previously just referred
over to 1002 PLC 1002 for the
application fee if you flip to the next
page here you'll see the relevant
section of 53 or 52
2023-52 which has the the section so it
has this table here table 1002.10 it's
titled application related fees for
professions regulated by the executive
director with the advisory Court Board
of court reporters if you look here it
says court reporter licensing
application processing as initial in a
renewal and then a duration and then the
fee amount looks pretty clear that these
are licenses right you wouldn't have an
application that has a two-year duration
you have a license that has a two-year
duration
so
um
and so you know like I said with this
construction it looks like that they're
equating the application processing fees
or the application fee and the licensing
fee
and you know that might be okay for the
Advisory Board of court reporters
because the statute and that's your next
page it states that the applicant shall
pay fees for the application for a
license it doesn't say they shall pay a
fee for a license right it says they'll
pay for an application
and as I previously said this this issue
impact impacts other proposals currently
in rulemaking and some that have already
been approved for example and that's
your the next page it's going to have a
a section from the statute on the board
of Forestry
so right now there is initial proposal
for the board of Forestry and in that it
does state that the fees are
non-refundable however that statute that
you have in front of you says that um
it's pretty clear that only one half of
that licensing fee shall be paid at
application the other half gets paid
whenever they get approved and when they
want to get their license
only does that half of that fee become
an application fee if the license is
denied
now currently they have a IP that's you
know in process that says that the
application processing fees are all
non-refundable but clearly the statute
doesn't state that
so
um you know we were going to recommend
that perhaps The Proposal the fee
proposal 2020 352 be postponed until
oplc can go through and make sure that
what's being included there actually
lines up with the statutes but again to
summarize
um you know calling the fees for court
reporters application processing fees
might be okay because of the way that
statute reads but it's not going to be
okay for every single other board that's
listed in 52. I I just highlighted one
and that was on the Foresters I think
there's also an issue with mert the
medical imaging radiation board as well
there might be some others but we don't
have the bandwidth right now to go
through every single one and check all
the fees and there is some
some squishiness if you will around
reinstatement fees what does the statute
say about that is that a application fee
or is that a license fee so yeah that's
kind of a high level of what's going on
with the proposal
oh perhaps
ah well let's see if we can
deal with the court reporters first
while we mull over this fee issue so is
the
um
in the court in the court reporter rule
96 is that
does that include non-refundable
application fees it does and like I said
the statute there says that they're
paying for an application for a license
and there's another section that it it
like I said it's a little unclear but it
could be that when they renew they're
actually paying for the license and not
for an application
depends on how you how you interpret the
statute well clearly the the application
for license is allowed but then the
renewal is not necessarily an
application right so offhand I would say
that the hundred dollars is the
application fee in the 200 is a license
fee but that's just my interpretation
right
and if you look at the um 52
on that table it has the renewal and
then duration is 200 but you know this
table is is you know titled application
related fees so you know like I said
they're they're kind of lumping
Licensing and application fees you know
together and so and then saying that
they're all non-refundable and I think
that's problematic
thank you I agree any other questions or
comments
yes if I can respond uh so the way the
oplc treats it is that it is an
application fee so if you're going to
spend the 155 dollars you wouldn't send
in your application for
whatever the license type might be that
initial application that would include a
check hopefully not stapled to it but
sometimes it happens
um
for the application processing fee but
renewals work the same way because
there's also applications for renewal of
licensures so they the fees even for
renewals even further statements are
application fees at the oplc they are
not fees for licensure and we worked
with doj on this issue to make sure we
got the verbiage right because there is
a concern about sort of the difference
in non-refundable licenses for
application fees versus a licensing fee
and so that you have no licensing fees
as far as I understand we have no
licensing fees we have application fees
or fees for application for a licensure
interesting
comments
I would point out that if you look at
the licensing of Foresters in your
handout
[Music]
um
if you go down to about the middle of
the paragraph the fee for a license as a
Forester shall be fixed by the board
that doesn't say the fee for an
application
yes so part of that could be part of our
cleanup it's been the ongoing process
that we've been Shifting the fees for
the boards to the oplcs we made a lot of
progress in that last year removing the
specific fee setting Authority from the
boards it is my understanding and I
heard it said here at gelgar that it was
the legislative intent for oblc to have
the fee setting Authority so this that
Forester piece I think would conflict
with 655 as it was moved forward
assuming it's signed which gives the
office the fee setting Authority I think
it's already there in RSA 310a1e
uh and then I think the Forester piece
would also be part of that cleanup
project as we move forward
um this fall as planned
I think it may come down to whether or
not the legislature agrees that um there
are application fees or license fees
right like I said with this forestry
um statute it's pretty clear that only
half of that fee is due at the time of
application and the other half is due
whenever they get their license if you
look at that last line as there it says
should the board deny the issue of a
license to any applicant the fee
deposited shall be retained by the board
as an application fee it only becomes an
application fee if the license is denied
rather
well but the Forester thing doesn't
affect the court reporters
all right
I can't I I guess I
it's hard for me to believe that the
legislature really intended to draw a
distinction between application and
license in this context I mean I I agree
that the the Forester one talks about
um you only have to and I'm not quite
sure why they did this but you only have
to pay half of it in the uh when you
when you make the application but he
I just think that that trying to draw a
distinction where we're sort of
overthinking this it's an app it's yeah
it's it's one feet that's well I could I
can agree that if you have a higher fee
for initial licensure than you do for
renewal the difference is pretty clearly
an application fee because in many cases
there are a lot of things that have to
be approved for initial licensure that
do not have to be redone every time
so that makes sense but the
the renewal fee I'm not sure I see that
as an application fee and I I have to to
say that that the
um
the normal understanding in the
legislatures the license fee is
something you pay for the services of
the board
and that you get benefits from it
um
I think it's more just that well
and for for example we just just passed
a bill that said that the any surplus in
the oplc fund will be used to reduce
license fees well if they don't have any
license fees what are you going to do
with it
oh Heather Kelly director of operations
uh
to clarify application fees are
considered the initial application fees
those fees are the fees that we refund
renewal restatement fees are not
considered
application fees and we do refund those
there are additional license fees that
we collect the professional health
program fee for example is considered a
license fee we have a wall certificate
fee verification those are not the
issues right it sounds like there's a
bit of confusion in the office I'm not
the finance Guy this is why I brought
Heather with me today I thought I was
speaking correctly but I'm glad Heather
came and corrected the record uh Lindsay
would have been here because she and
Heather typically do the the finance
piece and I'm sort of subbing because
she is in Alabama right now
okay uh we're just going to point out
that that's not the way it's set up in
2020 352 and that includes for the court
reporters they're like I said they're
lumping them all together under the
title application related and in the
proposals they're saying that
application processing fees are
non-refundable period and that includes
renewals okay well then case I think
there's an issue in the in the
uh basic
PLC 1002 to clarify the distinction
between license fees and application
fees
because we're getting two different
stories
um for the court reporters
we are up against our deadline what is
the current status of the rules
sorry there are interim rules and they
expire at the end of July
um
court reporter ruled to the our July
meeting
and get a waiver for it and also
postpone
the the
general fee related rules
part of your motion still yes the
postponed the two of them
to clarify what's an application fee and
what's a license fee because apparently
there are some
disagreement on what's what and we'll
need a waiver on both of them second
okay okay any comment question on that
okay
those in favor
aye opposed
okay we'll
we don't deny that there are application
fees but they're not all application
fees
all right and
okay so the next one would be 20 23 51
which is fees not for licensure but for
the site visits and inspections that are
not related to licensure and even though
it is only a one-page proposal there are
a number of comments on there just
because we're facing the same issues as
we are with the licensing fees about who
has the authority to set those fees each
board that is listed in this proposal I
did cite the statute
and for your information I will go
through all of them yes but it does
explain there's some conflicting
statutory Authority and then
additionally some of these boards also
already have rules establishing fees for
site visits and inspections so there'll
also be a conflict if these rules were
to go in effect
the conflict in the rules this ought to
include the
delete the repeal of existing rules that
have different fees or actually any fee
just to make it simpler
but I but I believe the statutory
Authority is working its way into law
yes that should be cleared up and yes
with regard to the existing rules an
expedited repeal of the
individual board rules would certainly
eliminate that conflict okay can can you
arrange for that to happen the expedite
if we approve this we also want to have
the expedited repeal of existing rules
that set fees I can have that happen
okay thank you
and that was all the comments I had on
this proposal all right then I will move
to approve
this rule
with the condition that the conflicting
rules
be
expedited repealed
second on that okay
any questions or comments
great thank you very much I don't know
which fees are said in other rules but
you guys can figure that one out
all right and for the last one for oplc
today
um oh we ought to vote on we ought to
vote on oh sorry uh the representative
Rhoda
okay those in favor
aye opposed okay thank you very much the
last one
um and I won't spend too much time on
this because just like the court
reporters
um this was a board that was turned into
an Advisory Board the recreational
therapist
um there was there was an interim rule
in place uh and so this is just a
regular rule making for those rules and
it has
um similar issues to the court reporters
with regard to the fees refundable
versus non-refundable
um
additionally there were a couple
substantive comments
um one about the retention schedule
which we also won't get into because
we've had that conversation before and
um a couple comments with regard to
citations to the PLC 300 rules that had
come through a month or two ago there
were some unclear comments on those PLC
300 rules that did not seem to be
fixed in the adopted rules so I just
made a comment on those to bring up the
issues again the first being on page
four
the rule sites to PLC 304.04 C and in
304.04 C does not make clear that that
portion of the form is only for
applicants for reciprocity the form does
make it clear but the rule text itself
does not make that clear and that was
not fixed in the adoption
um
so
they're um when do when do the
current interim rules expire
I believe it is also July I believe this
these rules came about the same time
that the court reporters did they're on
the same track
okay
in that case I moved to postpone them
with the same issue as the court
reporters
um
and we hope you will address the other
comments while while you're at it
okay Eric yes representative Leon a few
seconds oh okay fine I thought it was a
well Michael okay
any other
discussion of of that uh
of this rule
those in favor
aye
those opposed
okay so we will postpone those three
rules to clarify the fee issue and in
this case there's also some other
comments that you can pick up at while
you're at it and can I get clarification
on that issue because I believe the
statute gives the oplc authority to set
fees for and it specifically states
initial applications renewals read
statements all of all of the fee setting
Authority and right and I I share the
opinion of Representative Lynn that we
might be getting a little to pedantic so
what is the concern about the difference
between an application and a license fee
that you would like specifically
addressed so that I can I think um well
like we like we said earlier that um
some of the statutes do differentiate
that the license or that the fee that's
paid only turns into an application fee
whenever it's
um denied and uh there are not just with
the Foresters there are a couple of
other place other boards that it impacts
as well in regard to the recreational
therapist the question is are if are the
fees all application fees or some of it
licensing fees and the difference is
that if
license fees are are potentially
refunded and I just want to make clear
that yes the statutes for the
recreational therapists do give the oplc
the authority to set the fees for this
board
um
but once again it's a little
unclear what is a license versus what is
an application fee
we're not arguing that the fees are are
in themselves inappropriate the question
is how they're classified
so I I think we I definitely don't want
to have a situation where sometimes it's
this sometimes it's that unless it's a
Tuesday you know this is too much
Hopscotch I don't think we have to
decide either there is a difference
in some cases and not in other cases or
whatever but we need to think this
through much better because it's it's
kind of like
spider on a web they know how to do it
we put our feet in the holes
okay it's just like what representative
McGuire said because one type of fee is
refundable the other one is not so the
public or the licensees need to know
right so you were you talked earlier
about cleanup and this definitely needs
to be cleaned up right in my concern
though is or it was my understanding
from a legal interpretation now
Heather's a finance individual so we
might be coming at a different
perspective but but my perspective was
we put application fees and if you look
at the 1000 twos that we did not address
today every one of those says
application processing so to me I our
intent was clear these are application
processing fees
except that as a legislature I don't
believe that we think that all the fees
are application processing fees we
believe that there is at least some
portion of the fees that are paid that
are a license fee and the app and
and that we'd like you to be clearer
about it if you decide they are all
application fees we're going to need
some better backup okay okay thank you
for clarification
we will look at that did you vote on the
post moment
I thought we did yes
oh we did what vote on the postponement
of recreational therapists
yes okay
all right
Board of Nursing
okay we're on the home stretch here
um this is
2023-69 the board has uh submitted a
conditional approval there's just one
comment I have on
page two of the rule text
because this um the the language says
the person may be fined fifty dollars
for every calendar month and it keeps
going
um the May is the the real issue is that
um you wouldn't know
how much that they may be charging you
and they may not not charge you
um and so I've made a suggestion in the
Box down at the bottom to change it to
shall and kind of reword the sentence to
make it a little clearer
um and so that's the only change it
really needs to be made if the
department doesn't want to
use my entire suggestion as long as they
change made a shell then it should be
okay
good morning Tina Kelly the office of
professional life insurance
certification
um it was my understanding that the last
sentence clarified they maybe maybe fine
they may be fine and the board shall
apply the factors described in nursing
40204g when determining the amount of
fine so that was to clarify when that
fine
would be
what would how the board would determine
when that fine would be applied and how
much would it be applied
um that actually doesn't
um
correct the problem just because they
like the fifty dollars is is the the max
right and so they can they it's not
clear that they can be fined up to fifty
dollars
and
um
the the
board is is giving a fine but they have
these determinations of why it would be
less
yeah if I do I understand correctly that
the shell applies to the board
determining what the fine should be
in reading that shall be fined no matter
what there'd be no determination as to
you know what the circumstances were is
if you say shall be fine that everybody
will be fine fifty dollars for every day
that that goes by but then the next
sentence gives them the it gives you the
context in which they would determine
how much so would adding in Shelby fined
up to work
okay
I guess I'm I'm confused what is the
problem with the use of the word may why
why shouldn't the board have discretion
to decide whether they're going to find
right why that I mean is there there's a
statute
that's specifically prohibited in the
manual because a in the manual May is
used only to Grant discretion to say
example licensee someone outside the
department if the department wants to
show discretion they say shall if or
shall unless and then they give the
criteria if the criteria could be
extensive or it could be a couple
example examples and some very general
language as the overall Criterion
because if it simply says may you don't
know what the Department's going to do
in uh in an uh specific insurance
instance they could say well it's
Tuesday so we're going to do this uh I
mean it's Sally allows for
if if the manual says that then my I'm
not this is beyond today but the manual
should be changed because that's crazy I
mean respectfully it really is the if
the if they decided if the if the rule
said May and they decided that we're not
going to apply it today because it's
Tuesday and there was an appeal that
would be flipped in a minute and it
would and and fees would probably be
assessed against the department for for
making a crazy decision it's I mean it's
There are rules
that you know all over the place that
say May and it did to give a board
discretion I just don't understand I
mean you know court rules are full of
those kind of things it just it seems to
me it's perfectly appropriate to to give
an agency discretion to make a decision
now it may be a problem I'm not saying
it may not be appropriate to also put in
some criteria on which you would use it
on which you would exercise the
discretion but to say to to tell a board
that you know you have to do something
that seems like I just don't understand
that well the the statute I believe and
the manual both give ways to
have discretion so we can you know the
the boards the agencies the
Commissioners they can they all can have
discretion
um they just do need to put in criteria
so that the people that are reading the
rules understand what is going to happen
and so it's it's not that we're not
wanting them to have any discretion we
just it it needs to be clear to the rule
reader what they're they're going to do
I guess I it seems to me that just was
really sort of overthinking it but
even with criteria if it says the agency
May impose this fine if one two or three
it's still okay maybe one two or three
exists uh so they've committed a
violation but the word may means the
department can disregard the fact that
there is a violation which is exactly
what they should be able to do I mean
it's that that's the
that just seems to me that you that
that's what discretion is all about I
mean if they again obviously if they
abuse their discretion if they if they
do something like saying you know we're
not opposing the fine because it you
today's Tuesday obviously they could
that could be reverse or if they said
we're not imposing the fine because
you're an African-American or or you are
or you're not an African-American or
some obviously discriminatory basis I
think that would get flipped right then
I think we're going off on a tangent on
this case the the the I if you wish to
take up the issue please
um yeah but it but the right now the
manual does say that it should it should
be shall
and
um
in this case where the
um that there are specifically
criteria for to determine the amount of
the fine
that you know up to fifty dollars would
make sense to me
although I do would prefer to say that
they shall be fined because that implies
that the board will evaluate the fine
not it may they may come up and say
shall be fined zero but they should the
board should be looking at what the fine
should be
in my opinion
so does the department agree with um
changing the language language to shall
be up shall be fined up to
so my question would be
if the board after putting in the
criteria described in Nur 40204 G
determines that a fine would be
inappropriate
yes that would work yes even if it shall
be up to it could be zero yes okay then
I'm fine with that okay
any other questions are concerned
all right seeing none
on movie conditionally approve
seconded by Senator Ward any further
discussion
assembly Shanley I'm sorry
your voices are very similar
and all right any uh
further discussion or comment
those in favor
aye opposed no
all right representative the record
representative Lynn votes now thank you
the rule is approved
okay
so 2023 89 is the Department of Health
and Human Services the rules on Foster
family care licensing requirements
the department did file a timely
conditional approval request but I
apologize it was not reviewed and put on
the website till yesterday
um it unfortunately
there was a bit of a miscommunication
and it was not um addressed as quickly
before this meeting but it is online now
and the conditional approval does
address all of the substantive comments
except for one which is a unclear
legislative intent comment on page five
of the rule text and
this
has to do with 541 a 29 which requires
within a reasonable time not exceed 60
days after the receipt of an application
petition or request or response to a
timely request made by the agency uh the
agency shall approve or deny or commence
an adjudicative proceeding however the
requirements in this rule for
licensing a foster care placement
includes a lot of
additional information it requires
background checks it requires an
inspection of the property by the fire
marshal by the building inspector so all
of this additional information could
exceed that 60-day statutory timeline
however this is all information that is
clearly important to this particular
licensing procedure so this comment was
made back in 2020 when this rule came
uh through the committee and it was
approved as written but I just wanted to
bring that to your attention again this
time thank you
good morning Allison radmay
administrator for the administrative
rules unit at the Department of Health
and Human Services
foreign
Jenna Wilson of the division for
children youth and families in the
policy unit
and finally Beth margison chief of legal
Regulatory and legislative affairs uh
for the division and I oversee the
policy unit
questions
um would it be reasonable to to say
something like the 60-day period applies
after all pertinent information is
available or the application is complete
because I believe that's an exception in
that in that schedule
it could certainly be phrased that way
because the statute does say or the
response to a timely request made by the
agency and so those additional
documentation could be
could be construed as that additional
request for information so just
clarifying in the role that the decision
will be made within six days after that
I think because I I agree that you don't
want to it hand out a license because
the fire marshal hasn't been able to be
there in 60 days but
um
uh we're just conferring here
you might say something yeah
I have never sat before this committee
before so good morning
um so
we have what we call an application for
foster family care which is just a very
very initial piece of paperwork that
comes into our agency and then there are
all
um like five supplemental forms which
include the the fire department
inspection
um the release of criminal records and
all those documents and it actually
states in the rule
um
hec6446
.06 D3 that we don't consider it a
complete application until we receive
actually all five lice references back
for the applicant
so once we have all of those things it
becomes a complete application
so that is
where is that specifically stated
6446.06 D3 okay
[Music]
so we're looking on page five
um Appleton shall be complete on the
whole uh
on all of those things so on average
it's taking our applicants about 40 41
days to do that process from the initial
form 1725 which is just that very uh
letter of interest for application
and um
from the time that we have everything up
in including the the five references our
processing time on our side to say yep
your application's complete please go do
that home study where they have somebody
come in and do an evaluation of their
home that's uh one to two days in our
office so we're looking at about 40-ish
days to do all of the initial paperwork
we process it and get them assigned to a
home study uh within a couple of days
and then it's not in our control anymore
so I if I understand you correctly
you're saying that the statutory
requirement of issuing the license
within 60 days
is not a problem
I'm not saying that
well so the home study
um requires uh sometimes a consultant or
uh I sometimes I think a a staff member
to go to a home and do quite a long list
of things I'm not familiar completely
with what the home study entails but
based on the data that I ran for the
past 12 months it's taking
I want to say like uh right around 100
days for because the what what's
required often you know there needs to
be an appointment for this consultant to
come to the applicants home maybe things
need to be fixed
um so the applicant may change those
things like they need to have GFI
outlets in their kitchen they have to
beat certain requirements to have their
uh fire exits if it's a if the basement
is a sleeping area there's various
things that may need to be corrected and
it could be a back and forth process and
it also relies on the applicant being
responsive
and those aren't things that we have any
control over once that home study is
complete and we receive it back
then we issue the license but it's that
interim period between the time that
we're processing the application we say
yes you may have a home study they do
that work and the students we get it
back
and the home studies approved then we
can issue the license
if I can add that that process is taking
um according to the data that Jenna
crunched about 100 days
um
pardon me can I ask clarification on
that is it a follow-up thank you is it a
hundred days from the time
100 days for the home inspection and the
repair or 100 days from the time they
send in their first application to the
time until all everything's done
it's 100 days from the date we say you
have a complete application we're
assigning you a home study so that's
when the 100 days or approximately
that's what it's taking is 100 days to
start to them when we say yes your
application is complete you are a
candidate for foster family now go do
this thing
that is with not within our control and
when we get it back that it's approved
then we will issue your license
and I just want to make sure that I'm
clear so it sounds like the home study
is that also included in six four four
six point one five or is that in a
different section
I see director Morrow did you say some
or is there some comment yes
um a few years ago the
time period under 541a in which you have
to act on an application was reduced
because the legislature was concerned
that there were too many people applying
for licenses who were waiting months and
months to have action taken so the
period was shortened but gel car in the
past has realized that's not one size
fits all uh situation so the committee
has used its statutory discretion
because you're not required to object to
even if there's a black and white
basis for objection
thank you madam chairman thank you for
that clarification and um if this
hundred days is after the complete
application do you know about how long
it takes from somebody beginning the
process to being a certified Foster
family I do have that data just give me
one moment um
so from the moment I'm sorry are you
talking about the moment that we have
the initial application packet that's
typically taking them about 40 days to
get processed with us from saying hi I'd
like to be a foster family I'm going to
start this process of filling out these
forms so we don't maintain data on the
we get several emails phone calls
contacts that say I'm interested we
don't begin that clock until we receive
the form 1725. so that's when I can give
you data it begins then and it's 161
days average over the past 12 calendar
months
but what I can tell you is there are
some who they send in all of their
initial paperwork and they're done in
less than a week we get them their home
study within a couple of days
they're good to go their their house has
no issues there's nothing to do they get
their consultant right in and there are
folks who are who are licensed within 30
days
it just it's a matter of how informed
they are of the process if they've got
sort of all their ducks in a row
it varies quite a bit
so when you go in to do a home
inspection are you looking for more than
a building inspector would look for as
far as safety goes
I I don't know uh Senator Ward thank you
for the question uh because I'm not
really sure what a building inspector
does when they do like a certificate of
occupancy I just know what we're looking
for in terms of Life Safety
um fire inspection and and and the like
okay
I do think the fire the building is
expected will look for all kinds of
safety things including fire and
electrical outlets and those kinds of
things
Senator Ward the issue is that in many
parts of the state there is no building
inspector
and therefore what you don't have a
previous certification that it was there
and then the building codes have changed
over time so that if you have an older
house it's very possible it might not
meet today's Life Safety report okay
thank you
all right I have a question for the yes
group so are we
is there a super concern that 60 days is
too short of a period because of all the
things that have to happen half not not
the pros not the application process
itself but it's what happens after
it's doing the home inspection and the
home repairs that have to be done right
and which which are difficult to
parse out so I'm wondering if there's a
way of clarifying that the 60 days apply
strictly to
the point is that the 60 days is for the
agency to process everything they need
to correct and it doesn't sound like
it's an issue in this case correct so as
long as that's clarified
does that take care of the rule
or the statue well so just including in
the rule itself that the application
because once as representative McGuire
said it's the agency acting within 60
days not so much as the applicant
providing the information in 60 days so
even including in the rule that the
agency you know shall act within 60 days
of receiving
all of the information
um
maybe defining what that information is
is it all the paperwork is it you know
the completion of the home study and
clarifying that way I don't think
legally it would
fix it as director Morrill said the
committee can use its discretion to
essentially say that they don't have to
comply with the 60 days in these rules
because of these specific circumstances
but it might not hurt having in the
rules that you know
a completed application is considered
all the information including the home
study and then the agency will then act
upon it within 60 days potentially could
be something that could help I would
feel that that that's an appropriate
thing to add that the agency will act
within 60 days of receipt of the Home
Inspection
clearance essentially that that there
are no issues left yeah because that's
that's why I asked the agency where in
the rules the home study was because the
section that was cited about what is a
completed application I wasn't quite
seeing the home study included in there
and I just wanted to make sure I wasn't
missing it either yeah so I think it
needs to be reiterated that the home
study is also included in being a
completed application
okay
I don't see where they do the home study
either
I apologize we're looking for the
appropriate spot to
the right thing okay
yes
um I guess what I will say at this point
is it does seem to me reasonable
um under that there are requirements in
place that are
um
dependent on the actions of the
applicant that the department clearly
doesn't have control of and and I just
think being you know us being aware of
that and recognizing that is important
I think it's on pages two and three one
and two of the fixed text there's the
fire department inspection and the home
health inspection
are those the ones you're talking about
the home visits
no the home visit is something separate
okay then I think
um but we are um we did find in section
uh six four four six point one five
would be the appropriate place to add
that uh oh I apologize uh it starts on
oh
nope one four I'm sorry I'm looking at
the wrong page
um Page Six
So within HEC
6446.14 that section that would be the
appropriate section to add
um that the licensing or the application
timeline begins
um I don't know what letter we'll put it
in yet but we're happy to add it in
there for you okay
fine
in that case I'll move that we
conditionally approve
representative Leon um thank you madam
chair um I did have some other questions
in here as well I'm not sure it seems
like there may be some constitutionality
about having people's personal health
information released from all federal
and state protections let me scroll to
that one here on
page four at the bottom you sign a form
providing your personal health
information stating I understand that
the health information I authorized
disclosed to the licensing agency may be
redisclosed as a part of the application
for foster family care and no longer
protected by federal and state privacy
regulations that seems to be a pretty
high request to people when we even
tried the right to privacy into our
constitution I recognize that there's
some competing interests of these
children and wanting to make sure that
they're safe but giving
taking away all protections for people's
personal health information seems to go
too far
thank you I hadn't noticed that that's a
very good point
so this is a standard uh this is a
standard language I'm sorry
this is standard language that is
included in everything and this is
um basically it's Federal Regulations
say that you have to it's not that
you're no longer protected by federal
privacy regulations per se it's that you
are aware that you are signing something
disclosing information uh to the to the
Department
I don't know if Jenna has anything else
to add for that so
generally my understanding is that we
have to put people on notice that if you
submit this to us and then we have to
give it to the folks who are doing your
home study that we are no longer in
control of the information you gave us
you gave us information on an agency
form you gave it to an agency that's
responsible for your privacy however as
part of this process if it has to go to
the next person in the line such as a
consultant that does the home study we
can't we can't offer you an assurance
that that can be private because no
longer within our control
oh sorry it's a follow-up please yeah
that seems rather concerning because
with our personal health information and
any other situation there are controls
when that is disclosed to anybody else
and not having those controls to your
Consultants is is very concerning
especially because when you look at the
form that's included in here it has
things like any past history of alcohol
abuse let's say somebody abused alcohol
when they're 14 years old it's any in
sealed records it's in their medical
history now that's being shared with
somebody who doesn't have any disclosure
requirements from the department and
this could impact their standing in the
community and anywhere else that's it's
very troubling
will our foster care license
applications are confidential they are
not open to anybody in the community and
for the Department it's very important
in terms of when we're placing children
in foster care homes that we have a full
assessment of all the issues
um that the prospective foster parents
have have faced
uh
Senator thank you uh Madam chair I you
know
this is
in place for the protection of children
it's really clear it says in just in the
part we have in front of us
um
there are lines that are very clear that
I'm specifically releasing only the
mental health information listed in the
health history below
um it says I understand I am not
required to sign this form however if I
do sign so on and so forth I understand
the health information I I or authorized
disclosed to the licensing agency may be
redisclosed so nothing is being
it does not appear to me in any way that
this is being
um secretive or you know something is
being done against a person's will if
you want to take on the responsibility
of caring for children through the
foster care system there these are some
of the conditions which one must agree
to and that seems completely reasonable
to me
thank you as a follow-up I'm very
concerned I'd like to know what rules
there are regarding your consultants and
what Freedom they have or restrictions
they have on disclosing this personal
health information which would fall out
seems to me from your your statements
about the protections that happen within
the department are one thing but as soon
as you give this to a consultant you
have no control over that information
that seems to be a lot further than the
department determining that somebody's
prior medical history puts a foster
child at risk and by giving it to a
consultant who has no constraints that
seems to be a massive violation of
privacy
so any consultant that does work with us
is bound by our HIPAA privacy laws there
is a provision in HIPAA and I'm getting
a I don't want to because I don't know
HIPAA extremely well but there is
whenever there is HIPAA information it a
person has to authorize as Senator
Chanley said the disclosure of that
information it does not mean that the
it's just it's a provision for HIPAA but
our consultants and we have many child
placing agencies they are themselves
anybody who any entity that has personal
health information is also Bound by
HIPAA
sorry uh thank you uh the protections
given by HIPAA that people are commonly
understand aren't as strong as we would
hope and believe that they are
so when the department has contractors
um there's typically
various agreements and contracts that
they're that they're signing to be a
contractor of the department
um and that again is something that
is included in that contract they are
bound by whatever the department is
bound by
within privacy
follow-up uh thank you I guess I uh I'll
I'll back off of this one but I will
want before approving it I would like to
have more information on those
agreements and that protection within
those contracts I do also want to note
too
um there was an emergency rule that was
in place regarding an exemption for a
covet vaccine
um and this rule does also
um Encompass that exemption that we did
promise in 2020 if it came to be we
would add it into our rules so without
approving this rule that exemption does
go away
thank you director Morrow thank you
madam chairman
um I think the Departments sort of
addressed this already I was wondering
if the consultant is someone that is
hired by the department as opposed to
somebody being in the department and if
so I assume they're hired by contract
and that there certainly could be
something in the contract and say to the
contractor that you shall not the
consultant that you shall not release
the medical information
and that may be based on what they've
said
yes so
um
area of expertise but whenever the
department does contract uh with uh with
outside vendors
um there are
and it goes to GNC there are all
protections there are HIPAA Protections
in there there are
um what we would call business associate
agreements that allow us to share that
information so that protection goes
through the through the uh
um if I understand correctly
the health information may be
redisclosed as part of the application
that's fine that's what you do but I
don't believe that it's actually true
that it's no longer protected by state
and and federal privacy regulations
because you're enforcing them
as part of the process is that
I believe again I would defer to my
fellow panelists here because you know
but HIPAA requires a redisclosure
statement whenever you are
disclosing information and this is part
of I believe
just redisclosure yes you are
redisclosing it but I don't believe it's
no longer protected by federal
regulations federal and state
regulations because you are enforcing
the uh
the Privacy requirement on your people
and your contractors
at least I hope you are
Allison is perusing this right now so
so Allison if you look on page five
um a that second paragraph I kind of
liked it it says um I understand the
health information and then you move on
to the second sentence to the end it
says end no longer protected by federal
and state privacy regulations I think
that's what's being asked if that can
just be removed
we will have to look into that for the
committee
um as we understand it with standard
language
yes that's where we usually get into
trouble
representative land um thank you madam
chair I have a another another point and
another question to address as well okay
if we look on the bottom of page six
there is H1 which is speaking to all
children who are household members need
to be up to up to date on ASAP
um right now they're the language of
House Bill 408 has passed both bodies
and it's on its way to enrollment and
then to the governor
um that should happen before this rule
needs to be approved and that would make
those lines need to change because the
those children will no longer be the
only people in the State subject to the
asip requirements as a mandate
um so I would like to see that changed
before our next meeting so it'll be in
consistent with the language assuming
that the governor doesn't veto
um that bill because otherwise we're
looking at having stale rules it's
um
HB 40 requires the department to apply
for a waiver from the federal government
so that it
the reality is is that we don't know if
we have the waiver yet from the federal
government
it doesn't change these rules it
requires us to apply for a waiver and if
you get the waiver you will then need to
change the rules to agree with it we
will but we will not know that until we
have until October 1st to apply for the
waiver and then it's a several month
process after that okay so as if I have
a follow-up on that follow-up um that
that bill is a two-section bill
um the first that's the second section
requires the waiver but the first
section states that upon passage there
shall be no vaccination or immunization
requirements required of any children
residing in a foster home that exceed
the vaccination or immunization
requirements under RSA
141c20a and either in type of
vaccination or quantity of doses is that
still not yet into law when it becomes
law
then the rule will have to be changed is
that correct yes but it is not yet law
and again I don't have the most recent
version of HP 408 I I must confess I
didn't follow it through I don't know if
it went through the committee of
conference because the two thousands
were different but my uh recollection of
the first section of this of the bill
was in current statute that that was not
an amendment to current statue but I
don't again I don't know what the uh
what came out of the committee of
conference okay well as a follow-up I'm
actually the vice chairman of that
committee we did not have a committee of
conference we agreed with the Senate and
that is in addition to the law I'm
thinking that with all of these
different issues I wonder if it would be
appropriate to move postponement because
the jail card diedline is not until July
24th and to try and have some clarity on
these issues and see if this has been
signed into law at that point
I'm not sure if that would be an
appropriate motion manager um and just
oh sorry I am going to say that this is
actually something that's in current
rule
um so I don't know how that even affects
at this point if we hold off on this
well and I also just to reiterate what
Allison said earlier uh part of this
rule is also an emergency rule right now
to exempt Foster families from having to
vaccinate their children with the covid
vaccine so if this is postponed that
emergency rule will expire and therefore
will no longer be valid the emergency
rule expires when
um just a moment unless Allison has it
right off the top of her head
I actually think it expired within this
process a couple weeks ago oh it's
already expired yeah
yeah then never mind
but I can come well since it's already
expired we don't need to worry about it
exactly
um we we could move to postpone it or we
could preliminarily object
and I would like I'll move that we've
preliminary object until you can resolve
the privacy issues
because I'm concerned about that
okay
any discussion no no we need more
information
all right did we have a second yes yes
representative lay on seconded
hey
no no further discussion those in favor
uh opposed
okay thank you very much we have an
objection and we hope you will
give us some more information the last
one is 2023
55 Marie waited very patiently
um uh we pulled this off consent is
about employment 300 rules and
um it's just a minor change but it was
substantive so we wanted to do a oral
conditional approval on page two of the
rules this is under EMP 30302
um subsections two and three on page two
um the the numbers you see in
um two and three are incorrect and so
they want to change the The One and Two
from 51 to 500 cross that out and make
it
10 500.
and the other one in number three you
would cross out 501 and make that 10
501.
and the agency can explain why it was
that they needed to change those
you know
good morning Madam chair members of the
committee my name is Marie Helen
baylinson and I'm here on behalf of the
New Hampshire employment security
um the yes the um the
um rule wasn't consent calendar but when
I was doing the final review yesterday I
noticed that um there was a substantive
change basically as you understand from
our rule filing the rules uh generally
relate to
the different methods of filing
requirements dependent on how many
employer employees the agent or
employer is filing the employee tax and
wage report on
um current rules so so it could be paper
report electronic uh via a CD or
um by our online web tax system well
recently we've expanded our online web
web tax system made changes to the
system so that an employer or agent can
file the entire tax and wage report
um if they have if they're filing on
behalf of up to 10 500
employees or um what they call wage
lines because an employee can have a big
enough wage that it takes up two wage
lines so we in our current rules we have
500 employees and so that's inaccurate
it should be ten thousand five and then
so 51 to 10 to 10 000 five employees and
an employer agent can file
um on the um online on the webtech
system or um
or via paper report in electronic media
and then and it reverts back to paper
and electronic media if there are
um more you know ten thousand five or
one employees or more so that's the
that's the
um
that's the change that we would like to
make like to have the opportunity to
make to make things accurate before we
can um ask the committee whether we can
adopt the rule
discussion questions
someone have a motion
thank you
I'll move the we conditionally approved
with the the corrections as noted
okay okay
thank you
this further discussion those in favor I
opposed
all right thank you very much thank you
very much Madam chair yes I was
uncertain as to who the second was
a little bit ahead
he hasn't done
all right Madam chair we do have I
believe one item of other business
which is
um Okay so
so there's been
um some public testimony that came in
after the last fish and game rule
um and the concern
of
is is that some of the fish and game
rules May violate The Endangered Species
Act
so um I did some research and
um
their concern was that the fish and game
coyote hunting roles are violating The
Endangered Species Act because
um a New Hampshire Hunter could take a
wolf
um on accident while hunting coyote and
the argument is the same as the if you
remember the bobcat
argument it was it was they could take a
lengths which is on the endangered
species list
um and they're at that time Aaron wrote
a comment and said that there's no
evidence of a bobcat or of a lynx being
taken so he couldn't make a
determination if it violated the rule
the law
um this situation is a little different
because the gray wolf was actually taken
off of the endangered species list in
2021 January of 2021 and those are the
only wolves you would find in this area
and So currently they're not a part of
The Endangered Species Act anymore there
is legislation or I'm sorry there is
um some cases that are going through
they're trying to get it back on the the
list but those cases have not been fully
gone through the full process but as of
now
um the the rules are fine because the
gray wolf is not on the endangered
species list we wanted to bring this to
your attention one because there was
some concern but also because
um this Endangered Species Act
um argument will likely come up in other
um
thing so we wanted to let you know like
why they're being decided differently
here
all right so we I
have to nude meeting that was my
question if it was a consensus of the
committee to cancel please let's so our
next meeting will be July 20th which is
a Thursday we're going to our summer
schedule
yes that's true okay
anything else so you guys
yes so for example if by if for some
reason the gray wolf is put back onto
the endangered species list then what
would happen
um then we would need to to reevaluate
whether or not the fish and game rules
would violate The Endangered Species Act
and like I said with the Bobcats he
didn't confirm that it would because no
one had ever taken a lynx so
um I did actually ask if anyone had ever
taken a wolf and nobody brought me any
evidence of that so we would have to
reevaluate
when the Bobcat rules were up the
committee did enter an objection uh
final objection based on the fact
there's a potential violation of The
Endangered Species Act
but that was as Christina said links
were endangered species and I believe
that fish and game went ahead with their
rule regardless of our objection we
certainly didn't bring it to the house
actually no they did not uh they
withdrew the rule so there is no hunting
or trappings of uh Bobcats
interesting
all right thank you all
okay